bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 78 lactu le journal de la
rédaction 26 minutes pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale voici les titres
de ce 3 septembre la National 10
couverte en 2018 attrape l'enfouissement
de cette route qui voit passer chaque
jour 80000 véhicules est en passe d'être
lancé l'état vient de donné un coup de
pouce financier de plusieurs millions
d'euros les écoliers retournent à
l'école et ils sont plus nombreux cette
année plus 879 dans les écoles publiques
du 1er degré et plus 110 dans les
établissements privés du département une
rentrée marquée par les nouveautés aussi
et notamment la réforme scolaire et puis
l'équipe de France de football est dans
les ivelines depuis CLIRE fontaine elle
prépare les deux prochaines rencontres
des éliminatoires pour le
Mondial la semaine de 4,5 jours c'est
donc la principale nouveauté de cette
rentrée seulement 8 communes sur les 262
que compte les ivelines se lancent dès
ce mois de septembre c'est le cas de la
ville de trappe et c'est notre image du
jour ces écoliers trapiste devant
l'école Jean jurè vont devoir s'habituer
à la nouvelle organisation de leur
planning Doren avant les cours vont se
terminer à 16h15 le Lundi Mardi Jeudi à
15h55 le vendredi le mercredi matin il
ne faudra pas oublier non plus de faire
sonner son réveil et pour en parler plus
en détail la première adjointe au maire
conseillère général du département
Jeanine Marie est en plateau avec vous
tout à l' nous reviendrons aussi sur ce
projet d'enfouissement de la National 10
dans votre ville que j'évoquais en titre
pour le moment en direction la commune
de La Verrière comment s'est passé la
rentrée dans cette commune plus
particulièrement pour les élèves de
Nicolas Perrier c'est un jeune
enseignant de l'école du bois de l'éan
le reportage d'Antony res et d'élo
dimoine pour l'instant sa classe est
vide et silencieuse Nicolas ajuste son
plan de table et pose les carnets de
liaison de ses futurs élèves pour sa
première rentrée scolaire ce jeune
professeur des écoles stagiaires est
impatient de découvrir sa classe de CE1
pour une première journée prise de
contact ça ça être beaucoup de choses
administratives la préparation des
cahiers faire des choses comme ça après
on va expliquer aussi ce qu'on va faire
pendant l'année commencer certains
petits rituels qu'on fera tout au long
de l'année comme parler du temps de la
date des choses comme ça arrivé dans la
cour d'école enfants veulent à tout prix
savoir dans quelle classe ils seront
tout le monde scrute les listes pour
savoir si les copains de l'année
dernière seront là tu vas être dans
quelle classe alors CE2 CE2 et tu vas
retrouver tes copines oui tu es content
d'aller à l'école oui le cartable il est
prêt
nonce qu'il y a dans le cartable des
dessins tu sais ce que tu vas faire
aujourd'hui oui qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire du
travail mais pour certains quitter maman
pour rentrer en classe se fait à recul
je s seul très seul très seul on est
nouveau ici
donc attend désespérément de se faire
des Copin alors les CE1 on fait un beau
rang de par de s'il vous
plaît une fois ces 23 élèves installés
Nicola délivre ses premères consignesous
les jours on de la
lecture nouvelle année de découverte et
d'apprentissage une mauvaise surprise
pour les familles des clés sous-bois ce
matin la réouverture de l'école Victor
Hugo a été repoussée l'établissement
avait été ravagé par un incendie en 2010
des travaux de réhabilitation et de
reconstruction à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros devait s'achever cet été
l'entreprise principale en charge du
gros œuvre a abandonné le chantier fin
juillet les préfabriqués qui
accueillaient l'école les élèves depuis
maintenant plus de 2 ans dans la la cour
de l'école Jesse sont donc mis à
contribution encore une fois cette année
les navettes scolaires gratuites sont
aussi maintenues la mairie recherche
toujours une nouvelle entreprise pour
reprendre le chantier aucune date de
réouverture n'a été communiquée trappe
ou encore poissi les communes qui se
lancent dans la mise en place de la
réforme du rythme scolaire dès cette
année sont finalement assez peu
nombreuses en France environ 4000 soit
un écolier sur quatre seulement de
concernés Jeanine Marie bonsoir vous
êtes la première adjointe au maire de
trappe également conseillère général des
Yvelines pourquoi votre commune la ville
de trappe a fait le choix de se lancer
dès cette rentrée dès 2013 dans cette
réforme du rythme scolaire je pense que
les résultats de des des enfants dans
les écoles nationaux les écoles les
résultats nationaux dans toutes les les
écoles ne sont pas satisfaisant tout le
monde est d'accord là-dessus donc il
fallait agir vite pourquoi attendre une
année de plus pour ces enfants là autant
leur donner le plus tôt possible la
meilleure des chances alors ça veut dire
qu'il a fallu s'organiser très
rapidement il a fallu s'organiser très
rapidement mais euh ce matin nous avons
fait le tour euh des des écoles que ce
soit le maire les services et et
l'ensemble des délégués dans les
conseils d'école et ce qui nous revient
ce soir c'est que la rentrée a été très
paisible très calme et euh tout le monde
satisfait de des travaux exécutés des
des coins mis en place pour euh le
couoning euh des des des de l'ensemble
de cette r rentrée et pour nous très
positive voilà comment se passe à partir
de cette rentrée une semaine type pour
un écolier à l'URE de primaire au niveau
des horaires au niveau des
activitéscolair égal les horaires ont
été modifiés retardés de 20 minutes le
matin la pause méridienne est inchangée
et il termine à 16h15 de l'après-midi
ils peuvent rester jusqu'à 16h30 ce
quart d'heure est un quart d'heure
offert aux parents c'est gratuit et puis
après la journée se continue comme elle
se passait précédemment un temps
consacré au Boutter aux leç et puis les
activités qui vont commencer avec les
prestataires de service lundi prochain
alors justement pour assurer toutes ces
activités vous avez dû recruter le
recrutement c'est bien passé alors on a
recruté on a voté les les postes en juin
tous les recrutements sont faits je
crois que ça fait 44 postes au jour
d'aujourd'hui qui sont pourvus qui sont
sur le terrain et puis les prestataires
de services sont sont prêts à partir
quel montant pour la commune oh ça
dépasse le 1lion 5 il y aura des
subventions qui seront versé par l'État
céit auss la qui avait été dit mais
c'était la contrepartie pour les
communes qui se lançaient dès cette
rentrée 2013 à hauteur de 90 € 000 éèves
et on a 9 € par élèvez qu'on est loin
du chiffré aujourd'hui mais qui est pas
terminé pour l'année scolaire alors vous
nous disiez les familles les élèves ont
plutôt bien accueillli cette réforme ce
matin nous sommes allés sur place pour
nous rendre compte de la situation
recueillir quelques témoignages au micro
d'éod très mal c'est super mal fait
l'école mercredi c'est pas évident pour
les parents qui travaille comme nous
l'école le matin 8h50 c'est pas possible
ça le maire il voit pas que on on peut
pas on peut pas déposer nos enfants à
8h50 et les récupérer à 4h15 nous on
travail on fait comment c'est vrai que
le mercredi pour 2h30 c'est pénible un
petit peu mais bon on a pas le choix et
pour l'instant ça a pas l'air de poser
problème faut s'y adapter hein ça a été
prévu s'y adapté hein je peux pas vous
donner encore d'impression réelle mais
c'est vrai que ça a nécessité de
s'organiser différemment par rapport aux
années précédentes il faut s'habituer
parce que les rythmes sont nouveaux je
crois queon peut pas trop en parler
parce que c'est premier jour on verra la
fin de l'année on verra on fera le point
on verra si les enfants sont plus
reposés et s'ils sont plus épanouis donc
on verra ça en fin d'année mais je reste
sceptique les avis sont tout de même un
peu partagés c'est ce qu'on a pu
entendre en tout cas dans les
témoignages qui ont été recueillis par
par notre journaliste sur place ce qu'on
a pu entendre ce sont notamment des
inquiétudes sur sur le matin les gens
travaillent 8h50 ça peut faire tard
est-ce que des choses sont prévues avant
8h50 tout à fait depuis plusieurs années
et cette année euh dès 17h30 du matin
dans toutes les écoles sont prévus
gratuitement l'accueil des enfants pour
les deux parents qui travaillent donc il
faut s'inscrire au préalable en mairie
pour les gens pour maman qui Témo tout
ce qui activité municipale nécessite une
inscription c'est normal c'est un
problème de responsabilité voilà la
question du mercredi matin aussi par les
5 jours de la semaine il y a l'accueil
du matin dans toutes les écoles voilà
autre inquiétude le niveau de
qualification des personnes qui ont été
ils sont qualifiés ils sont tous
qualifiés même dans ceux qui sont en
Contrat d'Avenir certains on le B f je
crois qu'il y en a deux qui ne l'ont pas
mais qui sont en formation et en tout
cas ces deux personnes qui pourraient
paraître un petit peu plus fragiles par
rapport au rapport qu'ils ont et au
liens qu'ils peuvent avoir avec les
enfants sont dans une équipe renforcée
qui elle est une équipe solide sur le
plan professionnel donc ils sont pas
lâché comme ça dans la nature avec des
enfants on a on assume vraiment la
responsabilité de de de ces jeunes on
les a pris en pour être formé donc on
peut pas leur demander de d'avoir cette
formation là mais l'encadrement qui qui
qu'ils ont et peut-être plus renforcé
que ceux qui ont le BAFA un bilan sera
fait un bilan d'étap al bilan d'étape
est prévu d'ici la fin de l'année il y
aura pas de bilan intermédiaire d'ici là
pour
peutêrené le premier trimestre de
l'école nous avons prévu avec
l'Éducation nationale et tous les
animateurs de nous revoir de faire un
point d'étape puisque de toute façon les
animations qui sont prévues sont prévues
pour le premier trimestre donc il faut
voir comment elle marche comment on peut
réajuster ce qui nécessite d'être
réajusté et puis ensuite voir quelles
écoles vont prendre les activités qui
sont proposées peut-être d'autres
activités qui pourrai être proposé par
des enseignants j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y en avait qu' y avait quelques
projets donc pourquoi pas cel celle-là
aussi on va écouter quelques autres
réactions concernant cette rentrée
scolaire sur la commune de trappe des
réactions de parents d'élèves Nicolas
hardi il est président de l'Union
nationale des parents d'élèves autonomes
sur la commune de trappe et puis juste
après vous entendrez aussi Bertrand
mesure secrétaire général du syndicat
national unitaire des institut tuteur et
professeur des écoles sur la
commune bon j'ai fait j'ai fait le tour
de quasiment presque toutes les écoles
il me reste encore quelquesunes à
visiter la rentrée déjà c'est bien passé
les visiblement le créneau de de
8h50 tout le monde était au rendez-vous
déjà une bonne chose après quelques
impréhensions
subsistent
notamment le le créneau 16h15 16h30
visiblement beaucoup de parents n'ont
pas saisi qu'il y avait une inscription
à faire sur Cees créneaux là on se donne
je DIRIS jusqu'à la toussin pour juger
notre association met en place un plan
de vigilance où effectivement on
va par le BIA déjà de nos parents
membres et également des autres parents
effectuer des sondages
régulièrement au aux sorties des des
établissements les éléments
significatifs c'est une certaine
confusion autour des horaires qui sont
un petit peu compliqué euh c'est
d'ailleurs une remarque que nous avions
fait l'année dernière euh donc beaucoup
de parents qui n'ont pas encore pris la
dimension de ces nouveaux horaires et
euh comme ils ne sont pas les mêmes
suivant les jours et suivant les
demi-journées je pense que c'est une
confusion qui va rester encore un
certain temps nous sommes en train de
réaliser un une un comment dirais-je un
recensement plus exhaustif euh dans le
peu d'école où je suis allé les travaux
promis ne sont manifestement pas au
rendez-vous ou en tout cas il n'y a rien
de spectaculaire et donc une fois que
nous aurons fait ce recensement nous en
ferons le point avec la presse bien
entendu pour dire ce qui va et ce qui ne
va pas il règne encore une certaine
confusion sur ce qui est gratuit ce qui
ne l'est pas sur les publics qui auront
droit ou n'auront pas droit à ces
prestations et sur leur contenu Bertrand
mesure qu'on vient d'entendre parle
d'une confusion est-ce qu'il y aura
d'autres informations à destination des
familles peut-être moi j'ai CR
comprendre ce matin en faisant le tour
des écoles queil y av les mê il y a pas
du tout les mêmes échos on n'est pas non
plus dans le même camp c'est sans doute
pour ça mais je crois qu'on a pas le
même public hein c'est tout voilà pour
vous tout va bien la rentrée c'est bien
placée c'est une rentrée comme les
autres vous me disiez avant d'entrer sur
ce plateau c'était une rentrée rentré
comme les autres il y a pas eu autant de
confusion que ça sur les horaires quand
quelqu'un prend son train à 38 ben la
scncf le ramène pas à 35 parce que 35
c'est ou 30 parce que c'est un horaire
plus carré dans la tête des gens donc
moi j'ai cru comprendre matin que tout
le monde c'était bien fait aux horaires
et sur la gratuité des activités
certains son grat Activ c'est écoutez on
a annoncé que c'est gratuit une fois
qu'on a dit que c'est gratuit c'est
gratuit l'ensemble des activités restent
gratuites ben l'ensemble des activités
le le le périscolaire d'après 16h30
c'est le même tarif que l'année dernière
quelle que soit
l'activité voilà voilà pour les
précisions pour les familles qui nous
écoutent en marche de cette réforme du
rythme scolaire la rentrée globalement
s'est bien passé sur sur la commune il y
a eu un accord qui a été signé pour un
meilleur accord
meilleur accue pardon des tout petits
les moins de 3 ans une charte signée
avec l'Inspection Académique l'éducation
nationale ça va consister en quoi alors
on a eu la création de trois classes
spécifiques au à l'accueil des enfants
de 2 ans voilà la charte prévoit un
certain nombre d'obligations la ville de
trappe et j'ai tenu à ce que ce soit
comme ça sinon je prenais pas les
enfants c'est je considère que les
enfants de 2 ans sont encore des bébés
jusqu'à l'âge de 3 ans c'est d'ailleurs
des bébés puisquils sont en crèche le
j'ai voulu que l' encadrement soit le
même que celui de la crèche la charte
prévoit une adsem et nous on a mis deux
adsem c'est-à-dire un pour 8 voilà et on
a une éducatrice de jeunes enfants et on
a un coordinateur qui fait l'ensemble
des trois des trois classes je vous
propose de rester encore avec nous en
plateau dans quelques instants nous
évoquons un autre dossier qui concerne
votre commune l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 le dossier avance déblocage
de plusieurs millions par l'État on fera
un point dans quelques instants on va
encore parler d'éducation et de cette
initi tive de la FCPE la Fédération des
parents d'élèves elle concerne les
fournitures scolaires avec le
renouvellement de l'opération kit
collégien cahier calculatrice crayon à
moindre prix cela fonctionne tout
simplement par un système d'achat groupé
résultat parfois 50 % d'économie pour
les familles des élèves allant de la 3e
à la 6e une initiative saluée par
Vincent payon le ministre qui était en
fin de semaine dernière en déplacement
dans un établissement de mante la jolie
pour assister à la distribution de ce
kit collégien c'est une très belle initi
qui a été conduite ici par les
professeurs et les parents d'élèves et
la première chose que vous entendez
c'est ce rapprochement entre les
familles et l'éducation nationale
j'avais adressé au mois de mai ou de
juin une circulaire à l'ensemble des
chefs d'établissement pour leur demander
précisément d'associer dans la rentrée
des familles pour des raisons vous avez
raison d'économie on voit que là ce kit
ça permet d'économiser 30 % sur les
fournitures scolaires à la rentrée mais
aussi parce qu'on peut s'appuyer
là-dessus pour faire réfléchir les
enfants et travailler avec eux sur les
modes de consommation des modes de
consommation respectueux du
développement durable respectueux de
l'origine des produits qui les a
fabriqué dans quelles conditions et
c'est ce que font les professeurs ici en
marche de ce déplacement à mont-elajolie
dans les ivelines pour évoquer l'achat
des fournitures scolaires Vincent payon
a aussi fait un point plus général sur
cette rentrée en évoquant la réforme des
rythme scolaire forcément ou encore les
créations de
postes la fédération de parents d'élèves
la FCPE distribue ses quitte rentré sous
le regard du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui salue l'initiative et des
familles heureuses d'avoir fait quelques
économies sur l'achat des cahiers
classeurs et
calculatrices c'est extrêmement simple
comme démarche on n pas besoin d'aller
courir les magasins les professeurs se
sont posés des questions en amont de
savoir quel sera le matériel utile pour
toute l'année il y a un aspect financier
aussi qui est pas inintéressant puisque
on a vu qu'en moyenne il y avait à peu
près 30 % de coût inférieur au cours
individuelles en marche de cette
question des fournitures c'est surtout
sur la réforme des rythmes scolaires que
le ministre en déplacement était attendu
des journées moins longues et des
activités périscolaires plus nombreuses
pour les élèves et cette question
comment garantir un accueil de qualité
pour tous il y aura évidemment comme
toujours vous voyez des disparités sur
le territoire mais il faut que chacun
progresse et il faut que au fur et à
mesure on a mis les moyens nécessaires
et bien les activités soient de plus en
plus intér pour les enfants il y a déjà
des endroits il faudrait les saluer où
des choses exceptionnelles sont mises en
place pour cette rentrée d'une richesse
considérable et puis il faut aider les
autres ceux qui ne sont pas passés
d'abord au rythme et puis ceux qui ont
plus de difficultés à s'organiser à
faire le mieux possible cette rentrée la
première préparée par la gauche sera
celle de la refondation de l'école de la
République selon Vincent payon les
chantiers ne manquent pas nouveau
programme réorganisation des zones
d'éducation prioritaires des dossiers
d'autant plus sensibles que 2014 sera
aussi marqué par le retour des électeurs
aux urnes avec les élections municipales
80000 véhicules traversent chaque jour
trappe via la nationale 10 qui coupe
tout simplement la commune en deux un
plateau de 400 m de long va enfin être
réalisé pour recoudre la ville le projet
n'est pas nouveau mais il manquait des
fonds pour le concrétiser ces choses
faites explication Catherine zulato
Jonathan
villman une lettre très attendue celle
du ministre des Transports qui confirme
sa volonté de couverture de la nationale
10 à trrappe et selon ses mots d'avanc
rapidement sur le dossier une
arlaisienne sur le point d'aboutir et
forcément le sourire chez le principal
intéressé le maire guim Malandin depuis
2009 ce projet est bloqué pour parce que
des personnes je n'erais pas on n'est
pas là pour ça avait décidé de faire
passer le Tourou sur l'AL 10 à travers
la ville de trappe mais aussi à travers
les villes qui suivent jusque jusqu'au
zessardleroi et donc au changement de
gouvernement c'est comme ça j'y peux
rien les autres avec à prendre leurs
décision autrement euh nous avons
recommencé à à à travailler à discuter à
dialoguer à la fois au niveau politique
et à la fois au niveau technique le
projet présenté est conforme à celui de
2009 il s'agit d'une couverture
partielle de la nationale sur une
longueur de 400 m entre la mairie et la
station BP avec la création de deux
rond-points entre le début et la fin de
l'opération autres projets le long de
cette national 10 pour créer une
cohésion urbaine trois aménagements
surface le premer au niveau de la mairie
un large plateau urbain le second pour
raccorder la rue pierreesemmar et la
cour de la Corderie et le 3ème pour
relier les rues Montfort et carnaau le
projet global en fouissement et plateau
urbain est estimé à 100 million d'euros
financé par la Ville à hauteur de 100
millions la casquie pour 15 millions et
le reste entre région conseil général et
état de la part de de la ville bon de de
la Communauté d'agglomération du
département et de la région
ce sont des crédits fléchés des
engagements signés et y compris dans au
sein de la convention de rénovation
urbaine le ministre s'est engagé et donc
l'état s'est engagé si tout suit son
cours l'enquête publique pourrait avoir
lieu fin 2014 pour un début de travaux
en 2015 et une livraison en 2018 la
National 10 ce sont chaque jour 80000
véhicules ce sera alors une nouvelle
page de la ville à
écrire etan Marie la prère adjote de est
avec nous sur ce plateau cette
réalisation dès 2016 début des travaux
2018 pour l'achèvement c'est faisable le
calendrier va pouvoir être tenu et puis
surtout comment on a pu trouver des
fonds il y a encore de l'argent en
France pour ce genre de travaux mais
bien sûr qu'il y a de l'argent en France
bien sûr qu'il y en a on en trouve quand
on veut en trouver on en a discuté tout
à l'heure j'y reviendrai pas donc si on
veut trouver l'argent qui manque pour
faire la couverture de la National 10 je
suis sûr que quelqu'un le trouvera euh
que dire sur cette couverture pour moi
c'est c'est la véritable transformation
de la ville la rénovation urbaine qui
s'est faite sur le la plaine de nufle et
même en centre-ville porte des effets
très positif sur l'image de la ville
pour autant la véritable transformation
passe par le plateau urbain je crois que
c'est une avancée pour la ville c'est
aussi une avancée pour l'ensemble du
département parce que cette ville elle
est pas divisée en deux elle est pas
coupée en deux elle est en trois
n'oubliez pas la voie ferrée qui a quand
même une certaine largeur et qui coupe
qui coupe les habitations de de tout ce
qui est service public ou autre moi je
pense à tout le quartier Massé qui est
très excentré et c'est pas toujours
facile de vivre dans une ville avec un
quartier comme ça complètement mis à
part ce qui est dommage c'est que on n
pris autant de retard 400 m pour cette
ce plateau urbain qui va recouvrir la
nationale 10 c'est suffisant oh c'est
déjà pas mal hein 400 m certains aur
espéré forcément un petit peu plus loin
oui mais à ce moment-là on allait dans
une couverture totale et c'était un
tunnel et c'était un autre projet et
c'était beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
cher les études techniques les
consultations sont bouclées il reste
l'enquête publique il reste l'enquête
publique de la part de l'État voilà et
là c'est ce qui devrait commencer la
consultation devrait commencer d'ici la
fin de l'année et des travaux qui
pourraient ensuite durer jusqu'à 2 ans
entre 2016 201 travaux moi je ne
m'engage pas sur je m'engage pas sur les
les plannings je sais qu'en France on
aime beaucoup les plannings mais chacun
sur l'aménagement peut-être parce que
les gens qui nous regardent sont sans
doute très contents d'apprendre que ce
sera couvert assez rapidement maintenant
finalement mais il va falloir aussi
circuler autour de cette
nationalisteououi mais les plan de
circulation ça existe ça se défait ça se
refait ça ça s'ajuste en fonction du
nombre de véhicules qui passent par tel
ou tel endroit et c'est prévu dans le
dans le dans le dossier global c'est une
nouvelle qui tombe plutôt bien pour la
commune de trae ça permet de parler
d'autres choses aussi puisqu'il y a eu
des émeutes des événements sur cette
commune assez violents durant durant
l'été nous en avons parlé encore
d'ailleurs hier sur ce sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui quel état des lieux vous
faites la situation de votre point de
vue du point de vue de l'équipe
municipale et serine sur la ville de
trappe le dialogue a lieu avec
l'ensemble des communautés l'ensemble
les jeunes aussi dialogue a toujours eu
lieu avec l'ensemble des communautés ça
c'est de la relation du maire avec
l'ensemble des communautés je crois
savoir et je ne pense pas me tromper que
chacun qui a demandé à être reçu a
toujours été
reçu donc même encore il y a pas très
longtemps après les événements donc je
pense que cette relation existe après
euh ce qui s'est passé est passé euh
nous sommes dans un pays républicain il
y a une loi elle s'applique elle
s'applique pour tout le monde ah vous
respectez pas la loi qu'est-ce qui se
passe ça nous a pas inquiété de voir ces
images à la télé si ça m'a c'est
l'ampleur qui m'a inquiété par rapport à
un
fait quelqu'un qui ne respecte pas la
loi donc l'ampleur qui a été donné à
tout ça à mon avis n'est pas ne reflète
pas tout à fait le fait générateur de de
ça est-ce que ce dossier va jouer sur
les élections municipales pour on verra
on verra vous serez candidate sur la
liste du maire guimalon je serai sur la
liste de Meur Guy Malanda bien sûr qui
sera candidat donc pour un nouveau
mandat il est candidat il a dit hier que
le projet de la nationale ni il espérait
bien le mener jusqu'au bout donc s'il
espère le mener jusqu'au bout c'est en
tant que maire et passionné de
l'Urbanisme et de travaux dans la ville
comme il est depuis toujours je crois
dans sa vie merci à vous je rappelle que
vous êtes la première adjointe au de
trappe guimalandin également conseillère
général des ivelines et puis guimalandin
qui sera bien sûr le bienvenue sur le
plateau de notre rendez-vous politique
sur TV film municipal 2014 au prochain
numéro puisque ce 3 septembre l'émission
politique de la rédaction recevra
notamment Hotman nasrou il se présente
sur la commune de trappe au nom d'un
collectif citoyen avec le soutien de
l'UMP pour terminer ce journal quelques
mots des Bleus l'équipe de France de
football est à Clairefontaine dans les
Yvelines et c'est un nouveau coup dur
pour Didier Deschamp après le forfait
fait à d'Étienne Capou remplacé par
Maxime gonalon c'est au tour du jeune
Lyonnais Clément Grenier blessé au io qu
Jambet de renoncer à deux matchs de
qualification pour le Mondial 2014 en
Georgie en Biélorussie pour ce double
déplacement seul Blaise matudi
représentera donc les couleurs du Paris
Saint-Germain il devrait continuer de
porter son casque suite au choc subi
lors de la réception d'Ajaccio il y a 10
jours dernier entraînement à wi et puis
ensuite les Bleus s'envoleront ce
mercredi toute dernière information
c'est un peu du sport mais c'est surtout
de l'économie l'ouverture de Décathlon à
coignère c'est l'une des enseignes
chargées de redonner vie à la zone
commerciale du forum à coanière après le
départ de Castorama il ne rester ici
plus que quatre magasins sur une
quinzaine d'cathlon bénéficient d'une
surface de 3000 m² les premiers clients
sont venus nombreux pour plus de détails
rendez-vous jeudi 18h30 pour filco le
magazine économique de la rédaction
devient hebdomadaire cette année il est
toujours présenté par clair Cambier fin
du 78 actu de ce 3 septembre à retrouver
sur notre site internet rendez-vous
mercredi 18 8h pour un nouveau direct et
d'ici là sur les réseaux sociaux
excellente soirée les programmes se
poursuivent sur TV
fil